this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you
well it looks like we were convinced to
be here I was expecting a much much
empty room
he said video no it looks like in
Mystica I'm mineral for sale I'm one of
maybe five other computers in the world
and he seemed off to be diminishing
as as time goes on I've been hearing
that in Geneva number 2000 I came
straight from Wisconsin Madison where I
worked on Parkinson's reading
and cucumbers for my PhD and peers that
I work on tomatoes in Italy and I like
if you put great now it's in front of me
I can easily down about to close the
bridge perhaps a tequila bar
and my [ __ ] show
about 80 slide they're going to be quick
about this
okay it's my stance okay yeah Jerry's
okay so the first light is to
acknowledge a lot of people who work
with the human being program with my
Cornell then you can state what in the
state in the PDR you and of course
yes room 40 collaborators and
meaning so I
not least or I need to acknowledge the
people 19 that help us accomplish the
our day-to-day vehicles
so David and Sarah Todd too late charlie
his hand had been cut many trees
and these threes are
so oh wow a hundred years ago things
looked like this and now they kind of
look like this
nothing to get harvested so I the
difference
and of course that's praise that's
better access to i-476 today about 22%
of aqua rootstocks our door conferences
about and every every year about 12 in
the current
have you realized
so what do we ask
raises from the soil through
fenestration encourage soil chemistry
small microbes these letter other things
fight infections to collect engines
transfer set up and has to survive in
normal dislike
in 2007 and the straight line
this is
so based on the 2007 crop value without
any multiplier
and jeans
about
tortured soul yeah ten to fifteen
million dollars a year and the
difference between an opinion before you
and
it's probably the source of sausage it's
not 46 feet so that's about want to want
to
Lily's vertical perspective I was not
when all of this started so I have to
break the heard about dr. Cummings as
weeny having this this paper for future
in developing disease resistant apples
hey we're the only ones had been injured
the way the homework
everybody else was prompting so I net be
68 this program started a few very first
few reasons of Christmas no bold pieces
of 513 that 16 to a 241 5
and these are the last pieces 2:49
society
contend for the last piece of the
European process of course I enjoy
little
and so we have a range of different
something that describe
his reasons makers
in 96
more and productive
in Washington State and if you see it
here this is the state file that you
before in this is V 11 another title of
this program very productive is being
commercialized in the US and
internationally and I believe one of the
staple
this is before t1 of course I'm joined
the tree straight in and then as you
well know and the proof is like this
hidden but if so do the work
Oh sort it this crew stock is is quite
as far as what happens with replant they
hardly fire
my FDA so your money
and okay good news is that
next year's machine
slightly different problems
so there is over I wish that we give you
about 20 slides filling
very
and then it takes many years have
laughing females
and those three things to those
charities have to blend in
I'm grateful to Sarah Todd
leaders
the females
there's no rhyme or reason
to what we do
and how everything is planned out
this light to show that sometimes well
where people are used to tomato or porn
it's not like that
I'm fine well see some trades by the
private banking system takes one to
seven evaluation leaders who
these colleges cost complex this is
saying dwarfing a 12
so big what
we found evenings to
yeah
Oh
thanks to his fireplace cleaning and
inoculate the seedings that survived
with fire strike
that we have to find these and probably
use
in the field this is when I'm putting a
price tag to let you know why
so two years doesn't seem much up
every single one of these
but every single year the root system
picks out a number of shoes
Posadas useless production of proof
between then this nice case
but makes the point captain and
Apple suppliers which we then plant
then all these 370 plant in the field
evaluate
industry or TV
then
two types for and evaluate things living
off we don't like and tortured there's
three of course those eviction
and to go into stage 4 which is
profitable material
and
as
this is what we get
and
continue to stage 5 a lot
and we'll come to that and how much
using markers is important to society
baby is worth so for every single test
waterlogging violations
so the material that is asked tassels
those tests in
advanced
and measurements like the Constantine
sorry
we count suckers
try to read against suckers and then the
material that taxes those tags gets
placed over into red tiles the state
where we don't protect to be the best
and so we we want to see how these
perform
in a real commercial setting so that you
know
and then we have the same
and we at this day
tolerance
we look at
of the treaties now we know that some of
the media being attached to their main
program have a brand right --true
and you can see here
this is great he can be
amazing this is the same time
and we have
so what's the money
different stages of the theme program
and just business by state entities as
much as possible states free
I'm here
so now the $60
you know imperative $250
so developing a market strategy has been
reading program Harmony program and we
tried to combine building tools markers
map sequences of microwave meals causing
we have
then we might before this this pattern
piece of copper II Valley right now
we're process
so in 2001 we develop
the
or in Africa stocks these beatings and
libraries
lately we've done a little bit $3,000
we force a lot of money for the creamed
corn
so we sequence
I've heard of and you know for $3,000
that was like and possible sequence more
but because anyone million
one
Oh
and those have been very valuable
one of the most valuable thing
and that has paid off any time in
badminton marks as the identification of
unknown
any little story about four years ago we
began the process of propagating 241 by
T culture and student in the material to
several micropropagation nurseries for
them to take a class of the tool and
propagating into hundreds of thousands
of hundreds of thousands of plants after
about a year and a half this process the
nursery colony and about
oh they have
and and they said we're ready to go
commercial on this I said well great
nice - subject testing them on the
material and everybody else was having
poor success with the g41 because it's
very finicky with
propagation microphone and we found out
that it wasn't g-41 or something
different now when I can different these
plants before he want to eat I have
delivered them in a specific way they
were science on the phone exceeding
Bruce talk to maintain virus free status
because I wanted to maintain the
certification of the virus and of course
I had make sure advices don't take a
material you know the grass union and
someone to identify the specific plant
this is actually worth the differences
in groups to that divide Hoover to
California collect the sample specific
plant
and if I see
so
and be enough
alleles I'm formulating three
innovating program
Thanks this hospital right here
so these are functional needles for
of course their restricted day
in the reading program which is
represented here we have expanded on on
that degree of diversity but
so within the program a lot of marks
and we have been looking for
disease-resistant firing like an Indian
third marker that had
you know
tested number what I call a see what
the practice of those markers was in
this
and twelve discover new Eugene's moment
here
first not everything the literature
shows often useful
so we have this marker for
what I believe resistance we was built
by roofing use unit and it can to
Microsoft
but nine and nine five and do we know
that well but without testing it
and Valley RV
no this is an example was never marker
for the year - I was doing
of course the story here was public had
well it showed up as being not very
useful to recode
no videos and other other elements that
were in the public cater for example its
location was misplaced
this is the ticket proof but they gave
on a bus it on here - which is worth
worth quite a bit of money to be able to
select early on and and of course we
will
so to discover the best possible markers
we utilize set up a romantic orientation
gamification with 186 process under even
the parents were falsified these two
parents have yielded about 70% of the
releases in the in the u.s. division
quarter so it has been a very successful
crop very good specific combining
ability because of the different traits
that possesses it was blended in Geneva
in 2003 and we thanks to these workers
can one later
man we
he has crossed and we have used it now
things an explosive areas that are
linked to to about 25 different rates
during during this process many years
that several years the michaelis
population used to
collaboration with turbo fire light
powdery mildew resistance with
architectural description page
how working several
takes a lot of work
it's Maria's garbage in garbage out is
Mogu
correctly typing
you tell analysis here you're going to
come up with shown for no but they think
a little work and it takes a lot of
effort from education here's David
Strickland
pictures of approved
allies
plug this into it QTL discovery to come
up with
so we collected data
and utilized metric software very very
nice discovery
and you
of course we plotted results and charts
find the trade that's part of
who stopped and it's hurting our
population
any other ppl and for each for each a
needle that belongs
these are individual lowlife
honey so I dislocated his five for
private all hydrants given the presence
and you can see that one parent
and sometimes these are it's the other
pair with contributing alleles that
modify the trade so we have
combinatorial
and of course selecting for
or highest
okay it's time to try to do so well
about it and of my coffee and of my PhD
in Wisconsin I was theorizing about
marker census reading about secondary
population
won't it be cool if microwaves and just
barely started to come out make the make
up man
my
and use the challenges my courage I
relate find out what the
they spray them for where the expression
qtls
and well creams holy kings
Angela the foundation
make
and he'll pet develop in microwave or
alcohol
has about five six thousand images of
course that this represents now half was
the entire Apple Apple expressed
but still it's like themselves and its
intermediate between in research times
so the data comes out and this
collaborated with Tim acknowledged until
Henson
we took 48 and extracted DNA
and
hi related to the microwave and thanks
to the work that dip straight to did
with my comments and he was able to
knock 26 thousand ounces for each
individual
being motivated
of course I have to college
configuration painting
and second bracelet I have
in this degree so this is what the data
most like the expression because I
my mobile here kind of like a primal
where
one megabase
what I'm looking for is perhaps
something that is its transpose
not express the successful Express
something that makes motivations good
and all but and even if it's out of
these four how to be be gene it must be
close to it
gene so that I can market them like
garlic I mean of course me we have we
can look at gene families
or create pink families by the way
so here we have
one of the working for the genes that
are so we can actually study field and
actually did some work with the
anthocyanin genes where he put together
how couple of genes might model exactly
so
I
this is what you tell in public he has
markers that work
but this is the cancion that procreation
to see that a loss for about 40 LT that
it's got a very very common thing
this is a QTL for apple
nice box
courses in collage boards on here
and so we look at the
population excuse in this course and
powdery mildew
postmodern percent here is the
susceptibility and zero
if
so we can create a matrix
and compared to the
you can see that our needs are
correlated
and so
we have a nice affluence now published
by the tiny group
we can take the sequence of that of
those teams and put them on the map on
the
thanks to excellent
we can find out these are
having a line
we can find
and here is the vitamins to haplotypes
equally one for that regime and we can
see that
a number of
we can assign primers and these progress
typify this is the same
right here is this insane apricot he's
flying
and your eyes that would be like to us
open like to see
so
and selection using genetic tests what
we like to have perhaps a multiplex of
these types of markers
combined
oh you know the target targets for our
mantras of reading it's an ongoing
process we have more cards I have
he's fine non-disclosure agreement be
fine but I think wherever we are
we're starting exactly happily
resistance gene which will cut down on
the movie by half
one
I don't think that would need much
validation because therapy
maybe one so the future given our
we probably going to downsize our
orchards based on the tree to fire both
sides need to focus on discovering and
implementing different traits and we'd
like to continue the analysis
Oh
creates a commercial
and I came to say this I didn't I didn't
put much data here our work in utilize
collection
a needle but it's been central to have
normal school and we roof types in
behold upon the segregation of different
are teenagers find out
what the use of that is we have crosses
we need to find out how useful behaviors
are to the rowers how much money is at
work we have immunity
some more
of boundaries being fully so
have
nice
and finally
contrary to what people say
like Halloween
and recognized
variety
thank you
anyway
but we're done there no we're done
because it takes a lot of phenotyping
effort and money to do QTL mapping on
ground politics and I think we had the
material to do it I think the material
is segregated from knock collars but we
need to need to experiment so if anybody
hearing this has $40,000
yes
knowledge of markers and
Oh
I don't know
I believe it's possible
maybe even similar pathway as as as
the
really
I volunteer
they've been involved
yes
we didn't do any time this is so this is
the one one time
that's that's the time and we have both
shoes the shoes were
and
right I'm looking for things that
No
why
oh because it was a low-hanging fruit
we had to beta and I suppose if we could
avoid spraying roots of fields
No
the indica have any questions yes
I may have missed this because I was out
for a couple of minutes but it seems
that Casa D and warping are very closely
associated which I mean they're jeans
and close together on the same
chromosome or is it physiological
they're all different chromosomes
different ages and they are Denis is
illogical
so one affects the other and you can
think about it in a way what healthy
dies
production of flowers and himself and
then when Norfolk dies
and published so far that
Courtley degree to defy the payment is
makes the plant stop growth earlier in
the season than in the non work
one more place right conduct one more
question if you don't mind one of the
tests you were doing was a rat strength
test is that an indication of
the answer there is maybe yes
and to what we defined by solidarity
something that we've seen
the wood structure is different and we
see some brittleness groups and and of
course adventure because
two separate game types you have one key
in fact that may be more brutal than the
other and of course the more random
appears in the brief past so to answer
your question yet it may be
compatibility but it may also be the
rest of the wood
Hey
we have one more
kind of particular prey they have and
again
I
okay all of your modern room full of
virus problems
no we had wanted it is really
susceptible to viruses p16 which you
write this accessibility from malice
floribunda but and then we have somewhat
of differential susceptibility other
populations that we have discovered for
example that the same model three or was
the fight population seems to be
susceptible to one of the latent viruses
the kidnapped
we have enacted yet
it's one of the traces in the pipeline
we have to get the impacted wood from
the orchard
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu